BLEW UP ALMOST IMMEDIATELY IN
THE FACES OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THAT IS COMING UP.
BUT WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
SERIOUS NEWS, BREAKING IS OUT OF
THE MIDDLE EAST.
WE CAN NOW REPORT THAT THE
HOSTILE REGIME OF IRAN IS NOW
THE LIKELY CULPRIT OF THAT DRONE
ATTACK AGAINST MAJOR SAUDI OIL
FACILITIES.
ALL TOLD, THE ATTACK CAUSED MY
CAUSE 5% OF CRUDE PRODUCTION TO
BE INTERRUPTED INDEFINITELY.
REPORTING THAT AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE BELIEVES THE
ATTACKS WERE STAGED INSIDE OF
IRAN.
AND MEANWHILE, THE KINGDOM OF
SAUDI ARABIA CONFIRMED THAT THE
WEAPONS USED IN THAT ATTACK,
INCLUDING MULTIPLE DRONES AND
MISSILES, THEY WERE IRANIAN
DEVICES AND, OF COURSE, THAT
THEY FARMED OUT IN THE PROXY WAR
BY THE REBELS IN YEMEN AGAINST
SAUDI ARABIA.
THE REASON FOR IRAN'S
AGGRESSION, PRETTY SIMPLE, NOT
HARD, NOT COMPLICATED TO FIGURE
OUT, THE MULLAHS, THE ONE
OUT, THE MULLAHS, THE 1NE
OUT, THE MULLAHS, THE 11E
OUT, THE MULLAHS, THE 11 SUCH
AND DEATH TO AMERICA, THE ONES I
WANT TO WIPE ISRAEL AND THE U.S.
OFF THE MAP, THOSE SAME MULLAHS
WANT TO WIPE THAT OFF THE MAP,
THE SANCTIONS THAT ARE CRIPPLING
THE U.S. ECONOMY.
THEY ARE NOW SUFFERING FROM A
DEVASTATING MULTI-YEAR RECESSION
AS A RESULT OF THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES AND THE PRESIDENT NOT
TRYING TO BRIBE THE MULLAHS IN
IRAN WITH 150
IRAN WITH $50
IRAN WITH $150 BILLION IN CASH
AND OTHER CURRENCIES.
DEFLATION IN IRAN CAN NOW REACH
A STAGGERING 40%.
ITS CURRENCY NEAR RECORD THOSE.
MEANWHILE, BECAUSE OF AMERICA'S
NEWFOUND ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
THAT'S RIGHT, WE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, U.S. CITIZENS, WE ARE
NOW SHIELDING MORE THAN EVER
FROM THE CHAOS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IN OTHER WORDS, MAKE NO MISTAKE,
OIL, GAS, IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF
EVERY SINGLE ECONOMY ON THE FACE
OF THIS EARTH.
GEOPOLITICALLY, THIS IS LESS
IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO US, BUT
AMERICA'S MASSIVE CRUDE OIL
PRODUCTION, REFINERY
CAPABILITIES, PROVIDE THIS
COUNTRY NOW WITH ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND LEVERAGE AGAINST
HOSTILE REGIMES ABROAD INCLUDING
IRAN AND OTHER COUNTRIES THAT,
FRANKLY, HATE OUR GUTS.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS,
THANKS TO HIS POLICIES, THAT
AMERICA IS ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE ARE, THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
ALL THOSE YEARS, THE
SINGLE-LARGEST PRODUCER OF
ENERGY WORLDWIDE.
ANOTHER RECORD, ANOTHER CAMPAIGN
PROMISE BY THE PRESIDENT KEPT.
BUT IF THE RADICAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS, IF THEY GET THEIR WAY
AND ENACT THEIR NEW GREEN DEAL,
YOU CAN PRETTY MUCH KISS THIS
PROSPERITY AND ALL OF OUR
SECURITY GOODBYE, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THESE INSANE FANTASIES
ABOUT ENDING ALL OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IN THE U.S. IN TEN
YEARS, AND THAT MEANS NO
COMBUSTION ENGINE AND EVERYTHING
IS FREE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WOULD HAND
OVER OUR INDEPENDENCE, THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY, TO
EVERY DICTATOR AND DESPERATE IN
THE WORLD, YES, INCLUDING THE
MULLAHS OF IRAN, BUT EVEN THE
HOSTILE REGIME OF VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND THE HOSTILE AFTER THAT HE
IS.
YOU WANT TO BRING THE HOSTILE
REGIME OF RUSSIA, PUTIN TO ITS
KNEES, THAT AMERICA NEEDS TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL, MORE GAS, AND
GET IT AT CHEAPER PRICES TO OUR
WESTERN EUROPEAN ALLIES.
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY, I PROMISE YOU,
IT WILL IMPLODE, THE STANDARD OF
LIVING OF EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
WILL RISE DRAMATICALLY, WEALTH
CREATION ON THE LEVEL WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE THE WORLD'S GREATEST,
RICHEST NATURAL RESOURCES.
BUT IS THAT WHAT
ELIZABETH WARREN,
BERNIE SANDERS, AND SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY JOE WANT?
NO.
IF ONE THING IS CERTAIN, THIS
HOSTILE IRANIAN REGIME MUST BE
HELD IN CHECK, YET HE ANOTHER
TANKER SEIZED IN THE STRAITS OF
HORMONES
STRATA PROMOS
THE REASON IT'S IMPORTANT TO US
AND EVERY OTHER COUNTRY, THE
FREE FLOW OF OIL AND MARKET
PRICES, THAT MUST CONTINUE, THE
REST OF THE WORLD IS NOT AS
FORTUNATE AS WE ARE.
THE WORLD'S LEADING SPONSOR OF
STATE TERRORISM, WELL, THEY MUST
NEVER BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE OR
DEVELOP A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THEY SAY IT,
BELIEVE THEM, THEY WANT TO WIPE
ISRAEL OFF THE MAP.
BELIEVE THEM WHEN THEY SAY,
YEAH, THEY WANT TO THE
UNITED STATES OF THE FACE OF THE
EARTH.
THEY WANT TO KILL ISRAELIS, THEY
WANT TO KILL AMERICANS.
IT'S A SIMPLE MATH EQUATION, A
SQUARED +B SQUARED EQUALS C
SQUARED.
YOU HAVE THE CALIPHATE, AND YOU
MARRY THAT WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
THAT COULD MEAN A POTENTIAL
MODERN-DAY NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST THE
LIKES OF WHICH WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN.
IF YOU DOUBT THAT, LOOK AT THE
LAST CENTURY ALONE.
LET'S SEE, FASCISM, COMMUNISM,
NAZISM, STALINISM, JAPAN,
SLAUGHTERING IN THE LAST
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AT
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AA
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AS
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AT
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AO
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AG
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AH
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AI
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AT
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AW
COUNTRY, IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN, AL
HAPPEN AGAIN IF WE DO NOT ACT
NOW.
YOU CANNOT USE EVIL.
YOU CANNOT HAVE EVIL REGIMES
WITH THESE AGGRESSIVE
IDEOLOGIES.
INSTEAD OF GIVING INTO IRAN'S
ACT OF AGGRESSION, IT IS TIME TO
SHOW THE RADICAL MULLAHS IN THE
WORLD THAT THE U.S. HAS A VERY
RIGID BACKBONE.
THE PRESIDENT STATED VERY
CLEARLY HE IS LOCKED AND HE IS
LOADED THIS WEEKEND.
AND AS WE WAIT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REMARKS TONIGHT, LET'S TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO YET ANOTHER
IMPORTANT TOPIC, AND THAT WOULD
BE THE CLEAR BUSINESS MODEL
INSIDE THE MEDIUM UP CONSISTING
OF SPREADING LIES, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIBEL, DEFAMATION,
THAT IS ALL, YOU KNOW, PAR FOR
THE COURSE, ESPECIALLY ANYBODY
AND EVERYBODY CONNECTED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE NEW YORK
TIDES, THE SO-CALLED PAPER OF
RECORD GOT IT WRONG YET AGAIN
AND PUBLISHED YET ANOTHER LIE,
MISLEADING ARTICLE, TO SMEAR
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THE RECENT ARTICLE, SO-CALLED
JOURNALIST REPORTED REPORTING
ACCOUNT MADE THIRD THIRD PARTY
CLAIMING HE WITNESSED KAVANAUGH
COMMIT A ACCOUNT AND -- COMMIT A
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN COLLEGE.
HE HAS NO RECOLLECTION OF THIS
INCIDENT AND REFUSED TO BE
INTERVIEWED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY SHOULD HAVE PUT THAT IN.
THAT MIGHT'VE BEEN IMPORTANT.
MEANWHILE, THE THIRD-PARTY
SO-CALLED WITNESS WOULD BE A
THIRD
LAIRD
LAWYD
LAWYER WHO WORKED FOR THE
CLINTONS, IRONICALLY, DURING THE
MONICA LEWINSKY TEMPLATE IN
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORE
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORH
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORS
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORM
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MOR,
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORL
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORE
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MOR,
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORM
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORR
OTHER WORDS, COMPLETE B.S., MORE
BESMIRCH-MEANT, MORE DEFAMATION.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" LATER HAD
TO ISSUE A CORRECTION, BUT IT
DOESN'T MATTER, THE DAMAGES
DONE.
IT APPEARS THE NEAR COMES
WILLFULLY AND INTENTIONALLY
MISLED ITS READERS, AND TODAY,
THE PRESIDENT CALLED FOR THE
RESIGNATION OF EVERYONE INVOLVED
IN THIS STORY.
YOU SEE THE TWEET ON THE SCENE.
IS THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
THESE DAYS THE SO-CALLED PAPER
OF RECORD IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
MEAN-SPIRITED, SLOPPY,
ANTI-TRUMP PROPAGANDA ARM AN
EXTENSION OF ALL THINGS STATE,
DEMOCRATIC PARTY JUST LIKE THE
REST OF IMMEDIATE MOB.
LAST WEEK ON SEPTEMBER 11TH,
"THE TIMES" WAS FORCED TO
RETRACT IT TO BE DOWNPLAYING THE
ROLE OF TERRORISTS ON 9/11.
THE DAY BEFORE THEY WERE FORCED
TO TAKE ANOTHER TWEET PRAISING
COMMUNIST DICTATOR MAO, THE
GREAT REVOLUTIONARY FIGURE, AS
THEY CALLED HIM.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MASS MURDER.
IT WAS ALSO FORCED TO APOLOGIZE
FOR PUBLISHING A BLATANTLY
ANTI-SEMITIC TWEET DEPICTING THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL, OUR
CLOSEST ALLY IN THE MIDEAST,
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU, AS TRUMP'S
SEEING-EYE DOG.
IN A SEPARATE INCIDENT, AN
EDITOR WAS FORCED TO APOLOGIZE
FOR HIS PAST KIERLAND PAST
PURULENT ANTI-SEMITIC TWEETS
AND THEN THERE IS BRET STEPHENS,
IN A VERY PUBLIC MENTAL
MELTDOWN, BREAKDOWN, AFTER
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR CALLED HIM A BED BUG
ON TWITTER.
HE COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
SO BEDBUG BRET THREATENED TO
REPORT HIM TO HIS EMPLOYER.
WELL, MR. BEDBUG, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM.
YOU USED TO WORK IN THE SAME
BUILDING AS ME.
YOU FEEL FREE TO REPORT ME TO MY
BOSSES, I DON'T REALLY CARE.
NOW YOUR NEW NAME IS BEDBUG
BRETT STEVENS FOREVER.
IN JUNE, A PROMINENT
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER
FALSELY CLAIMING THAT
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW,
REMEMBER THIS, DIDN'T SUPPORT
THE 9/11 VICTIMS FUN.
THE PROBLEM IS, DAN CRENSHAW WAS
A COSPONSOR OF THE BILL.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THE MOST
BLATANT PACK SHOP BY "THE TIMES"
ACTUALLY BRAGGING ABOUT THEIR
ENTIRE NEWSROOM FOCUSED ON ONE
STORY PERPETRATING THE RUSSIAN
CONSPIRACY THEORY HOAX
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY LIED, THEY
ADVANCE THE BIGGEST HOAX
CONSPIRACY THEORIES EVER.
BUT BECAUSE THAT WIDESPREAD
EFFORT WAS A TOTAL DOUBT, IT
BECAME A LITTLE PROBLEMATIC.
WE ARE GOING TO NOW SHIFT THE
NARRATIVE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ADMIT WE
WERE WRONG.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE A
CORRECTION.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO FIND MORE
WAYS TO GO AFTER TRUMPS.
WE WILL GO AFTER HIM ON RACISM.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS KIND OF
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE IS REPLICATED
AND ECHOED ACROSS EVERY SINGLE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OUTLETS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE BLINDED BY THIS
PSYCHOTIC HATE AND RAGE, AND
THAT IS WHY THE MEDIA MOB IS
CONSTANTLY CHURNING OUT FAKE
STORIES, ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
JUST LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
OVER THE PAST TWO PLUS YEARS, WE
HAVE WITNESSED ONE PHONY, FAKE,
LYING STORY AFTER ANOTHER.
FOR EXAMPLE, REMEMBER WHEN NPR
LIED ABOUT DON JR.'S SENATE
TESTIMONY OR THE FAKE REPORTING
ABOUT MICHAEL COHEN'S FANTASY
TRIP TO PRAGUE WHEN HE HAD NEVER
BEEN TO PRAGUE.
THEN THERE IS "THE GUARDIAN"'S
FAKE BOMBSHELL BUT MEN AFFORD.
THE CNN STAFFERS FIRED OVER A
FALSE REPORT ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI,
THE MOOCH, AND NIKKI HALEY AND
THE CURTAINS, FAKE NEWS.
THREE PLUS YEARS, THE FAKE
REPORTS HAVE NOT STOPPED.
THEY DON'T APOLOGIZE, THEY DON'T
RETRACT, THEY DON'T CORRECT,
THEY DON'T CHANGE THEIR WAYS.
FIST RAISED TARGET EVERYONE
ASSOCIATED WITH TRUMP,
STARTING WITH HIS WIFE AND HIS
KIDS, EVEN HIS YOUNGEST SON AND
JARED KUSHNER'S BROTHER-IN-LAW,
NOW BRETT KAVANAUGH, THE
FIRST LADY OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, EVEN THE COVINGTON
HIGH SCHOOL KID THAT WAS WEARING
A MAGA HAD, THAT DID NOTHING
WRONG, NICHOLAS AND BEN.
THANKS
TO THE MEDIA, HE HAS ONE OF THE
BEST ATTORNEYS IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, LYNN WOULD COME, MY
PREDICTION, HE WILL BE, WELL, IF
NOT A BILLIONAIRE, PRETTY DARN
CLOSE.
TONIGHT, THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TIME
TO LIST SINGLE FAKE STORY FROM
THE MOB.
THERE ISN'T ENOUGH TIME TO LIST
EVERY BREATHLESS UNTRUE
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
LET'S GO TO FAKE NEWS CONSPIRACY
TV, MSNBC, RACHEL MADDOW,
LEARNING ABSOLUTELY NOTHING FROM
HER 2 1/2 PLUS YEARS OF FLYING
AND PUSHING HER CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
SHE NEVER APOLOGIZED, SHE NEVER
COULD CORRECTED THE RECORD.
SHE JUST DOUBLES DOWN ON STUPID
EVERY OTHER DAY, AND SHE PUSHED
YET ANOTHER HOAX LAST WEEK, THIS
TIME ABOUT THE U.S. MILITARY
REVEALING A PLAN NEAR TRUMPS
RESORT, WHY, TO BOLSTER BUSINESS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
IN REALITY, ROSWELL RACHEL THEY
HAVE USED THAT AS A STOP
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF TIMES
BEFORE TRUMP EVER BECAME
PRESIDENT.
MAYBE JUST A LITTLE
FACT-CHECKING MIGHT HELP YOUR
SHOW OUT.
ROSWELL RACHEL, SHE IS NOW THE
FACE OF MSNBC NEWS.